[Música]
ya directo a América llegó el momento de
hablar de salud y para ello ya está aquí
nos acompaña nuestra compañera más
Romero salamar muy buenos días Buenos
días Andrés mar vamos a empezar en
Estados Unidos concretamente en el
estado de Florida el republicano ron de
santis aprobó más leyes que prohíben
algunas terapias para personas trans
cuéntenos sí es una noticia que
desgraciadamente vamos repitiendo
también a lo largo del tiempo no esta
vez el objetivo han sido las terapias
Generalmente conocidas como servicios de
afirmación de género es decir todas esas
terapias que ayuden a personas trans a
verse como ellos desean verse no firmó
definitivamente un grupo de leyes que
permite a los menores precisamente
acceder a este tipo de terapias hablamos
por ejemplo de bloqueadores de pubertad
que son unos medicamentos hormonales que
digamos paran el desarrollo hormonal
característico de la adolescencia que
hace que adquiramos pues las
características tradicionalmente
concebidas como hombre o de mujer
también prohíbe la terapia hormonal para
menores que es darte testosterona o
estrógeno para adquirir precisamente
pues estas características estos rasgos
tradicionalmente femeninos o masculinos
para las personas trans y importante
decir en este punto Por cierto que los
bloqueadores son totalmente reversibles
es decir una vez separa la terapia
empieza a desarrollarse la pubertad de
nuevo de forma normal y la terapia
hormonal es reversible hasta cierto
punto su mayor parte de los efectos lo
son contrariamente a lo que dice el
gobernador ron de santis también se
prohíbe la cirugía de transición por
ejemplo la mastectomía y se penaliza los
médicos que ofrezcan estos servicios
obviamente esto es un paso más en estas
ofensivas digamos contra la comunidad
lgbt de estos estados pero
particularmente Y en este caso contra
las personas trans son 19 en total los
estados de Estados Unidos que han
aprobado leyes que prohíben estas
terapias en menores de edad Los vemos en
este mapa en rojo y hay ocho más en los
que están siendo debatidos esto Qué
significa que el 30% un tercio
aproximadamente de Los menores de
Estados Unidos viven en estados donde no
pueden acceder a estas terapias de
afirmación de género un paso más contra
las personas trans pero un paso menos en
la lucha por los por los derechos
exactamente ahora Qué efectos puede
tener estas prohibiciones en para la
salud de esta comunidad Sí pues son
múltiples pero nos vamos a centrar en
uno particularmente que es el aspecto de
la Salud Mental es muy importante
recordar que la prevalencia de problemas
de Salud Mental en la juventud trans es
siete veces mayores mayor que en los
compañeros y los compañeros cisgénero No
la mitad en 2019 de jóvenes trans en
Estados Unidos consideró el suicidio y
un tercio lo intentó Entonces en este
panorama verdaderamente lúgubre estas
terapias de afirmación de género según
unas las cifras de un estudio publicado
en el New england journal of medicine
este mismo año pueden tener realmente
una esperanza dar una esperanza a estos
jóvenes tiene un impacto muy beneficioso
este estudio revisó dos años en la vida
de personas trans tomando terapia
hormonal Y qué concluyeron Es que la
satisfacción vital algo que graduaban
con unos cuestionarios había aumentado
la depresión había descendido un 1,27 en
una escala de 63 puntos la ansiedad
también aproximadamente para que te
hagas una idea la mitad de participantes
más de la mitad de participantes que
tenían depresión severa pasaron de un
Rango de depresión severa un Rango
mínimo o moderado y un 40% de los que
tenían ansiedad clínica llegaron a tener
ansiedad no clínica después de estas
terapias para terminar con este bloque
Andrés también importante decir que este
tipo de terapias hormonales no es que se
consigan como en una máquina vendedora
expendedora No no es tan fácil sino es
un acompañamiento médico de años
aprobado por la academia estadounidense
de pediatría y de psiquiatría es decir
que tienen un aval amplio generalizado
en la comunidad médica vamos a cambiar
de tema vamos a ir a Dinamarca un grupo
de investigación quieren mejorar la
información sobre los abortos
espontáneos sí Andrés los abortos
espontáneos son estos que suceden no la
pérdida de un embarazo que sí era
deseado y lo que han hecho es la
prueba de sangre que normalmente se hace
en una pérdida de un embarazo a partir
de la semana 10 de gestación están
demostrando que da información también
muy importante antes de eso no cuando
los embarazos se pierden a partir de la
quinta semana de embarazo con esta
muestra de sangre lo que pueden es
secuenciar el ADN del feto del bebé que
se iba a tener y revisar si hay alguna
anomalía en los cromosomas estas
anomalías suelen ser responsables del 50
60 por ciento de las pérdidas
aproximadamente y si no es así revisar
Entonces porque es que ha sucedido
escuchemos a una de las investigadoras
lo separamos en dos grupos los que
tienen una causa de aborto y los que
tienen una causa desconocida
ahí podemos empezar a hacer preguntas es
esto es lo otro creo que los años que
vendrán son muy emocionantes porque
tendremos buenos datos de contexto para
contestar bien a estas preguntas sobre
los abortos espontáneos la reproducción
y la salud de las mujeres en general
ahora marqué opinan al respecto de las
personas o las mujeres las personas
gestantes que han pasado por esos
abortos espontáneos Pues la verdad
tienen opiniones muy esclarecedoras una
de ellas recogidas por la agencia GP que
hizo este reportaje escuchemos la
también
Creo que este proyecto hace que el dolor
y la tristeza de cada pérdida tenga
importancia por cada aborto espontáneo
sabremos más
y podemos usar las pérdidas para algo
más creo que este proyecto me da
esperanza de que menos mujeres deberán
pasar por lo que yo pasé
tal y como dice no es un tema este de
los abortos espontáneos que no suele
hablarse muy abiertamente pero que en
realidad es bastante común hasta un 20%
de los embarazos puede terminar en una
pérdida del bebé el 80% de estas
pérdidas sucede en el primer trimestre y
entre un uno y un 5% sucede a partir de
la semana 13 y entre la 19 es decir que
al final este estudio ojalá pueda
recopilar toda esta información no solo
para las participantes del estudio sino
que también será un contexto de datos
como decía la investigadora que ayude a
todo el mundo a comprender mejor por qué
suceden estos abor tos espontáneos y a
prevenirlo también en el futuro Así es
mar Muchas gracias por la información
sobre la salud mañana nos vemos con un
nuevo repertorio mañana volvemos